le versailles torcy c'était l'une des
affiches de cette sixième journée du
championnat de nationale 3 après une
première période équilibrée ponctuée par
un triste 0 à 0 les versets sont plus
entreprenants retour des vestiaires et
arrive à trouver la faille dans le
dernier quart d'heure grâce à un doublé
de benjamin louvet six fois buteur en
six matchs depuis le début de la saison
versailles parachève sa victoire grâce à
ioane akassou score final à 3 0
[Musique]
l'habitude de toujours bien commencé
commencé fort va réussir à marquer dès
le début là on est tombé continue
vraiment une bonne équipe bien en place
on a su être patient et franchement sur
la deuxième mi temps à mettre un petit
coup de folie pour pouvoir accélérer on
avait un petit peu de chance aussi
faut pas se mentir mais ça fait partie
du jeu avec six victoires en six matches
17 buts marqués 1 seul but encaissé
versailles réalise un début de saison
presque parfait des résultats qui permet
toujours de la cité royale de faire
cavalier seul en tête avec déjà cinq
points d'avancé sur le paris fc et à des
prix forcément parce que
pouvoir enchaîner autant de matches en
étant solide et en refusant la défaite
c'est que des choses se passent entre
les joueurs est l'état d'esprit le fait
d'avoir un objectif commun est de rester
une partition sur le terrain qui nous
permet d'avoir ce résultat prochain
match pour versailles ce dimanche 13
octobre sur le terrain de courcouronnes
en coupe de france
une victoire et une qualification pour
le 6e tour permettrait de bonifier
encore un peu plus ce début de saison
idyllique